John wick could have just been another
action movie but what audiences got was
something else entirely John wick
chapter three Parabellum hits theaters
May 17 and promises to take viewers even
deeper into the world of assassins and
their various vendetta's here's what you
should watch before you head to the
theater there's a lot of great dialog in
the first John wick film but we all know
which one is the true money line people
keep asking if I'm back and I haven't
really had an answer but now yeah I'm
taking on back it's as much a statement
about the character of John wick as it
is a battle cry for Keanu Reeves the
actor Reeves had a string of hits in the
90s including a little movie you might
have heard of called The Matrix but then
came the sequels after their mixed
reception it seemed like Keanu Starr was
finally descending he continued to work
on smaller films and passion projects
but he didn't truly rise to prominence
again until 2014 when he donned a suit
and dug up a lockbox full of guns and
gold coins in John wick Reaves was back
in the spotlight with plenty of momentum
and will even be returning to his first
iconic role and the long-awaited Bill
and Ted based the music alongside Alex
winter yes we're thinking he's back the
first entry and the John wick franchise
is incredibly straightforward for those
who haven't seen it
spoiler alert a man named John wick who
has recently lost his wife learns that
she had adopted a puppy for it he takes
the puppy in and loves it with all of
his heart for a single day but after a
chance run-in with the dirtbag son of a
mob boss things go wrong that dirtbag
son decides he wants John's car so he
goes and takes it and in the process he
kills John's dog this is a big mistake
mask why yeah well
because you stole John wicks car sir and
killed his dog turns out John is a
retired assassin who was so good at his
job that he's essentially the boogeyman
for other hired killers and he's mad
enough about his dead doggie to get back
in the game and destroy everything in
his path until he gets his revenge it's
a simple story but it's told incredibly
well smash cut - John wick chapter two
and we learn a lot more about the
secretive world of assassins this
globe-trotting adventure introduces a
high council of assassins and criminal
masterminds some of whom have unfinished
business with John wick himself enter
Santino Dantonio who has a favor to call
in say creeper descent upon it
no the job is simple kill Dantonio
sister Gianna so that he can take her
seat at the table of the High Council
John goes through with it and
immediately becomes entangled in a
conspiracy that leads to Dantonio
placing a massive contract on John's
head to cover his tracks the hunt for
John wick escalates to the point where
John is forced to kill someone on the
grounds of the Continental which is a
big no-no by the end of chapter 2 wick
is on the run with a one-hour head start
to outrun every assassin in the world
leading to the events of chapter 3 as
much as we love the specially minted
gold coins used by the killers in John
wicks world there's another currency
that's just as important blood markers
they're one of the few things that rain
in even the most brutal and relentless
of hired killers and a blood marker is
only earned when another assassin does
someone an immense favor they can then
claim that marker at any time to call in
any favor and return it cannot be
refused it's taken as seriously as
spilling blood within the halls of the
Continental
[Music]
exactly rules the reason John had to
take the job to kill a member of the
high table was a marker held by Santino
Dantonio one that he earned by helping
John get out of the assassins life and
go live his fairy tale existence with
his wife and peace before the events of
the first film by the end of chapter 2
as John wick goes to take his head start
in escaping with an open contract for 14
million dollars on his head
Winston gives him a blood marker which
may act as his only lifeline now that
he's been made excommunicate Oh from the
League of Assassins in the first - John
wick films we've already seen an
incredible roster of over-the-top
characters populating the shadowy
stylish underworld where anyone could be
an assassin just waiting for the right
moment to strike
that doesn't seem likely to change as we
get into chapter 3 with both returning
characters and some brand new faces Ian
McShane will be back as Winston the
manager of the Continental and Kiana's
matrix co-star Laurence Fishburne will
be returning as the mysterious Bowery
King a seemingly homeless man with a
deep knowledge of the world of assassins
and a love of pigeons $7,000,000 damn
it's Christmas we're going to Applebee's
afternoon here's hoping that the minds
behind the John wick franchise can find
a place for Kerry and moss
if she's interested completing the hem
Trinity seeing the three stars of The
Matrix reunited on screen even for a
short time would be pretty awesome as
for the new characters Parabellum has
upped the ante with an impressive roster
of stars Halle Berry will appear as
Sophia a former accomplice of John's who
wields two pistols and two dogs while
anjelica huston joins up as the severe
calculating director
Mark Dacascos will play the nefarious 0
while comedy favorite Jason Mantzoukas
will play the oddly named and
undoubtedly weird tick tock man Keanu
Reeves has been a lifelong fan and
practitioner of martial arts but few
roles have been as demanding of him as
John wick Reaves went all-in and spent
three months at a John wick boot camp to
work on firearms training bike
choreography and driving like a maniac
some of the training involved Reeves
working on his drawing holstering and
even search-and-seizure techniques this
helped him and the stunt team come up
with a unique style of movement and
gunplay no one moves quite like John
wick Reaves is also heavily involved in
the stunts it will be a wild ride to see
how the stunt team and stuntmen turned
filmmakers Chad Stoll eski and David
leach up the ante for chapter three as
John wicks world only continues to get
wilder and more dangerous one of the
best things about the secretive world of
assassins and gigantic super mario gold
coins that's presented in the John wick
movies is that there's just enough to
let us know that there's plenty we
haven't seen those looking for a
slightly expanded version of that world
however may have something to look
forward to there is currently a spin-off
television show in the works at stars
called the Continental it will showcase
a new kind of adventure in the world of
John wick focusing on a brand new
character who's pulled into the world as
the story unfolds stars has its eyes on
making a television show that captures
the slick porosity of the John wick
films and has tapped the original co
directors and producers Chad Stoll s key
and David leach as well as original
writer Derek Kolstad and of course
executive producer Keanu Reeves check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more
or videos about your favorite obsessions
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]